[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday August
22nd and I don't really have anything to
talk about today the only thing that my
brain is able to do right now is to
think about Paper Towns and I'm not
allowed to talk to you about Paper Towns
because I can't give away the plot or
the characters and so um today Hank I'm
like someone who's finally understood
the concept of zero I got nothing
Hank the thing about using awesome to
fuel your life instead of using like
gasoline or hatred or whatever it is
that nerd haters use is that awesome
burns extremely bright but it also burns
fast and so when you're out of awesome
you just kind of need some time to
recover and I don't know if you know
this Hank but we have to make these
videos every day so I apologize in
advance for being low on awesome alright
um three things the first thing is going
to be hair the second thing is gonna be
the website and then the third thing is
gonna be something really really funny
that I haven't thought of yet item one
hair best comment from yesterday Hank I
think your hair has a Horcrux Harry
Potter jokes are so jokes it occurs to
me now that the only problem with
adjectives in the word jokes is that
when you are trying to say that a joke
is itself jokes it becomes sort of
grammatically confusing then again it's
not like that's completely unprecedented
in the English language I mean you know
I shot the bear and that I had to bear
the bear back to camp by the way Hank
barring a bear extremely difficult for
most nerdfighters also in hair news
nerdfighter Ally is going to shave off
her hair if she raises $1,000 for the
Muscular Dystrophy Association you can
find more info about that here or
possibly here I don't have a sense of
direction or maybe even they're also
nerdfighter Melina Rana shaved off all
her hair except for a mohawk and gave it
to Locks of Love which i think is pretty
awesome thing to the website hank as you
know the website isn't working so well
right now we try to do this thing where
instead of running our servers on
electricity we are running them on
awesome but it turns out that we didn't
have quite enough awesome so the website
is going down constantly throughout the
day
unfortunately we
temporarily suspend the wikki wikki
wikki and there may be a couple of days
where everyone's going to have to go to
youtube to watch the videos but in the
long run Brotherhood to calm is going to
be back it's going to be more awesome my
pants are gonna be on fire and
everybody's going to be happy Hank even
if right now they're kind of mad thing 3
um something funny I haven't thought of
yet um in your pants jokes Hank in your
pants jokes are like the family in Tuck
Everlasting they never get old what do
we got over here how did they die in
your pants probably of suffocation
then we've got Susan Sontag classic
regarding the pain of others in your
pants Hank I do think it's important for
all of us to acknowledge how much people
have been hurt in our pants as you like
it in your pants Oh Shakespeare you
dirty dog we got the poems of Robert
Frost in your pants of course there's
that American classic two roads diverged
in a yellow wood and I
I took the pants leg less traveled by
then of course Hank we have a title for
those of us who often forget to zip our
fly The Escapist in your pants and
finally Hank we have Virginia werewolves
classic make lemonade in your pants
which is of course a novel in verse
about bedwetting Hank I'll see you
tomorrow